EDMONTON OILERS, THECHANCE.
APPLETON WITH THE FIRST ONE,
LOWRY WITH THE
>> Kevin: YOU WENT TO SIMPLIFY.N
GOAL, FIRES IT. HIGH -- SITTING
ON 24 HERE TONIGHTHTOING TO
WANT TO CAPITALIZE.
KUEMPER'S MAMA
>> Kevin: SIX SHY OF 50 FOR
CONNOR. WIDE DEFLECTED UP FRONT.
>> Kevin: I WOULD AGREE.
A NICE CHIP PASS THERE FOR
LOWRY.
FURTHER BACK
AND ADAM LOWRY AND FORESBERG AND
A CHANCE IN TIGHN, FOR DAIRN
HELMS.MATION.
HE'S BEEN MIRRORI
THE PUCK.
THERE'S LOTS OF CHANCES AND BOTH
GOALTENDERS HAVE BEEN EXCELLENT.
>> Dennis: NUMBER 1 IN THE WEST
BY DARCY KUEMPER.
>> Kevin: THIS GAME IS SOME TUR
OVERS IN THE COLORADO END.
DESE
GOAL OR TWO
CONSECUTIVE GAMES PLAYED FOR
COGLIANO AND A
PRETTIEST OF GOALS, BUT THIS IS,
TO THE NET, A REBOUND
CAUSING AND FORCING TURN OVERS.
BACK WITH THREE.
AND A SAVE MADE BY KUEMPER.
THAT SHOT MENTALITY. HIS OWN
NET FOR BYRON.
THE